I told you and have it applied.
Okay.
I think the first time I watched rick
reunite with Ilsa was during one of my
film classes in College Larson.
I have watched a great many old films
during those lectures.
Most of which I think both of us don't
really remember that well is we had the
tendency to doze off and those
comfortable sit in my seats.
That was until Cassa blank.
I came around and managed to firmly
break that cycle of it's quick witted
dialogue
and sambal memorable characters and of
course it's music.
Ooh,
the most of all is the film's overall
story that makes her such an enjoyable
viewing experience and it was only after
I'd read Robert McKee aptly named book
story that I fully came to understand
why kiss a blank.
I can be seen as a sort of gold standard
for great storytelling.
Soon this video,
I'd like to deviate from our usual
format and provide you a more practical
look into the realm of storytelling as a
whole.
To do this.
I'll guide you through and Mickey's
guidelines for scene analysis and we'll
take an in depth look and one of gas
blankets.
Most pivotal scenes.
It's
not a scene that I,
once you analyze its guests of Blanco's
midair climax,
which is being set up right here as rick
spots.
It'll saw walking around to market,
but before we get into that,
we first need to answer the following
question.
What makes a scene work?
Some might say it,
it's good dialogue or nice visuals and
although these things definitely help
when key notes to the determining factor
lies within the subjects.
Then the underlying structure of the
scene.
Now what does this mean within scenes,
we can make the distinction between
texts,
sensory service off the image or an auto
words.
Everything that we see and here on
screen and subutex,
which are all defaults,
feelings and conscious as well as
unconscious desires.
If the characters on screen and not a
words,
everything that is unseen or actively
being veiled behind the sensory surfers
of the text.
If characters lack multiple layers,
they tend to feel bland,
which causes them to feel fake and
dialogue to suffer as a consequence
which take a look at the segment from
bill harbor.
It's your nose.
What has happened here is that the
subtext has been written directly into
the text,
which is commonly known as writing on
the nose.
Good films,
on the other hand,
generally have derek characters express
themselves through subtext seems move
because conscious and unconscious
desires clash.
That's writers continuously up the
stakes and with dark characters on the
spot because they know it's the
decisions they make,
the actions they take that tell us more
about a character then any piece of
surface level dialogue ever could just
try them too.
You
not so fast,
lilly,
nobody is going to be arrested,
not for a while yet.
Now that we've covered that,
let's go back to the mid at climax and
analyze how it gets a blank.
I use subutex to move to seeing forward.
The first two things that we want to do
is one defined a conflict at the scene
and to note the opening value.
To do this.
We will need to briefly cover the
context of the scene.
So for those of you are already very
familiar with the movie,
you feel free to skip ahead.
Rick Blaine is a former freedom fighter
turned saloon owner and castle blank,
or during the Second World War as
cynical nature's revealed early on to be
caused by a devastating heartbreak he
experienced the year earlier in Paris,
his goal friend and soon to be wife Ilsa
Lund abandoned him.
Today you were supposed to escape the
city from the Nazis together.
Fast forward a year and a to run into
each other by coincidence and rick's
bar,
it'll sound,
however,
is not come alone.
And during the late nine meetup,
rick drunkenly,
he calls her out for being a horror as
she attempts to explain herself.
Tell me,
what did you left me?
Lazlo are there others in between?
Aren't you the kind of tell
after which you angrily barges out,
which takes us back to the market scene.
So did define the conflict.
We need to note the desires of the main
characters and play.
Rick initiated the Seton and despite his
inner resentment,
has goal is clear to when sub back her
motivations on the other hand aren't
clear yet,
but they're encounter tonight before
plus her guarded attitude right now give
away to,
she has an active interest in keeping
her affair with rick in the past.
The opening value of the scene is love
else's relationship to victor.
Laszlo has not been made clear yet,
so rick sees an opportunity to reunite
with his former lover.
The value is there for a positive,
which brings us to the first step.
Breaking the scene and two beats.
Now beat is an exchange of action
reaction in character behavior both on a
textual as well and more importantly on
a subtextual level.
So let's see if we can mark all the
beats in this scene.
You will not find a trade like this in
only 700 francs.
The first one is established right here
before either rick or hills.
I have even uttered a single word.
Rick's action is to approach her.
It was a,
on the other hand,
sensing his presence,
chooses to ignore him,
cheated
rick opens by protecting her from the
salesman and are now acknowledges his
existence but chooses to reject his
advances.
Rick's Voris who,
whoever seem to hint that more heals us
relationship with Laszlo.
Hi there ladies kinds of weeks.
We have a small discount.
Did I say 700 francs?
You can have a 200 I'm sorry I was in no
condition to receive you when you called
on me last night.
It doesn't matter.
No,
no special friends Albany cause we have
a special discount of 100 flags.
Brick now tries to hide his
embarrassment by using excessive for
melody to apologize for his behavior,
but it also remains unimpressed.
The story had me a little confused.
Maybe it was a boy bourbon.
I have some table called some neck pain.
I'm really not.
Please one minute please.
Still attempting to open up the
conversation he moves to excuse making,
but yet again hills or we'll have none
of it yet.
She doesn't choose to leave.
Also notice how the role of the salesman
is not really at all about comically
selling his lace to Ilsa,
but rather about selling rick to Elsa.
Why did you come back to tell me why you
ran out on me at the railway station?
Yes.
Rick desperately tries to get his foot
in the door by asking her a question
that provides his own answer and it
works.
It was,
that opens up just a tiny bit.
I do.
You can tell me now.
I'm reasonably showgirls.
I don't think I will rick
by insulting them.
Rick is at this point,
essentially begging tools are in his own
way where she's no longer rejecting him
completely,
but opposing him and asking for more.
Why not?
After all that got stuck with the
railway ticket,
I think I'm entitled to know last night
I saw what has happened to you,
the rain can you in Paris?
I could tell him he don't understand at
the one who looked at me with such
hatred,
rick losing his patient slightly moves
to guilt tripping ill zones to be an
explanation.
But both parties feel like dare to
victims.
So it'll say guilt trips,
rick right back.
How believing Casablanca soon and we'll
never see each other again.
We knew very little about each other
when we were in love in Paris.
We'll leave it that way.
Maybe we'll remember those days.
Not Casablanca,
not last night.
Ilsa now takes over to the initiative by
trying to see her goodbye to rick,
who then completely refuses to react and
instead starts to next beat.
Did you run out me because you couldn't
take it because you knew what it would
be like hiding from the police running
away all the time.
It can believe that if you want to.
So now he decides to hit her with his
best guests for an extra nation by
calling her a coward.
Those are no cysts to be false.
So she insults him,
ride back by basically calling him a
fool.
Well,
I'm not running away anymore.
I'm settled now above us alone.
That's true.
But the walk up a flight,
I'll be expecting you.
The spider continuous denials,
rick sends us her true feelings in
sexually propositions for two facts and
she tries to hide her blush on her hat
brim.
Rick now feels like she's almost within
his reach,
all the same.
Someday you'll lie the Laszlo,
you'll be there.
No,
no.
You say Victor Laszlo is my husband and
was even when I knew you in Paris.
But again,
rick can contain his pain and calls her
out for being a whore.
It was a haven't been called a slut for
the second time.
Reaches for the one thing she knows who
will hit the hardest because the
revelation that she'd always been
married to Laszlo would imply that she
just used rick for her own pleasure in
Paris and that our love had never been
real all along.
However,
the subtext of the scene gives away to
quite the opposite is the truth.
But of course rick doesn't know that yet
and was left devastated as Ilsa walks
off.
So at the end of the scene to hopeful
positive opening value has changed into
a deep and dark negative.
And the final step of our analysis,
we can see how to writers of guests a
blank and I've built a rapid progression
of beets,
each placing in governing value of love
at greater risk,
the 11 beat marks to climax and turning
point of the scene after which the
opening value changes to its closing
value.
Of course the scene is,
but a minor part in the massive full
piece of writing that is Casablanca has
basically every scene in a movie as
great if not greater than the one we
just analyze.
But it goes to show how much attention
to scene structure and subutex has gone
into the film.
And by having explored that,
I hope to shed a light minor as it may
be on a craft of screenwriting as a
whole.
Because even though your scripts like
Casablanca mine of a surface level
story,
that's as Corny as they come.
If the writing is good and if the
emotions are real and if the scenes
aren't what they seem to be about,
you might just have something special in
your hands
looking at you kid.
All right guys,
thanks for watching.
So obviously this video is quite
different from what we usually do and
it's something that I've been wanting to
make since we first started the channel.
I just felt like it didn't really have
the editing capabilities to pull off
just yet,
so it tells if you'd like.
These types of our practical slash
informative video is in between her
regular analysis and we'll be sure to
make more of them.
Also if you like what we do and one more
check at our patrion page where we
produce additional content and followers
on social media and all that good stuff.
Also,
one more thing if my voice sounds a
little off in this one towards the end
it's because I got a little sick during
the production of this video,
have recently moved halfway across the
globe,
so that probably has something to do
with it.
Anyways,
I think that wraps things up.
Thanks again for watching and see you
all the next one.